what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and Wow
boku no hero is really testing our
sanity with all of these twists and all
of this hype we just learned that the
new shigaraki is even more overpowered
than we realized something that I didn't
think was even possible because of how
strong he had already become the number
one Pro hero's life is an immediate
danger
I suppose life is in immediate danger
and sword the lives of many others
including Gran Torino rock lock and of
course deku and Baku go things are
really getting out of control so let's
get into it
if you enjoyed the book no hero content
on this channel and you want to see more
please slap a like to let me know and if
you happen to be new to anime lore or
you just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I keep repeating this but
it's important unless you go through the
trouble of hitting that Bell and then
selecting the option that says all
you're still gonna miss a lot of our
videos even if you're subscribed
it's how YouTube works you can also have
me up on Twitter and Instagram apps
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers we are dealing with the latest
developments in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the latest installment of the
story starts off with the Japanese media
finally reporting on what has been
happening in jakku we get to see all of
that vast destruction from the
perspective of a reporter in a
helicopter and by the reporters own
estimate nearly a third of the city has
already been destroyed there are many
heroes on the scene and they are trying
to evacuate as many people as possible
but as you can imagine all of this is an
absolutely terrifying sight for the
general public in Japan to see the scene
itself is absolutely horrific and
because of all the dust and debris it is
impossible to tell what is actually
happening just imagine yourself as
someone who is learning about this
destruction for the very first time you
see all those heroes you see all that
damage you see the evacuations but you
have no idea who or
what caused all this I'm sure that many
regular people are scared stiff as
they're learning about all of this
especially since similarly terrible
incidents have already occurred in the
past such as the Dacus City incident and
the Kamino incident to the media and the
greater public this appears to be yet
another large-scale villain attack in a
long line of such attacks if you've been
watching this channel for the past few
weeks then you know that I've been
saying that no matter how this current
fight ends the hero society will never
be the same again even if the heroes
somehow win the fact that the villains
were able to do so much damage in such a
short period of time is still going to
terrify the general public and this is
likely to make a lot of people panic
which will cause chaos the truth is that
no matter what happens from here many
people in Japan are going to lose faith
in the heroes and the pro hero system as
a whole and so as a result a complete
breakdown of the hero society as we know
it is likely to occur which is of course
exactly what the villains want
we then see brief glimpses of 'deck
whose mom baku goes smoking-hot mom and
Toad Rocky's family as they go about
their daily lives and then right after
being shown those peaceful and calm
images which emphasize the current state
of the hero society we see yet another
image of all four one is smiling his
evil smile inside Tartarus prison the
text that stretches across these several
pages is asking where this society this
country is heading now and I think that
the message that horikoshi wants to send
us with all of this is clear the hero
society is heading towards a much darker
and much more dangerous future the
current status quo will not continue for
very much longer
by the way this is definitely not the
first time that we got a seemingly
random glimpse of all-4-one inside
Tartarus prison in these recent chapters
in fact we've seen him several times in
a number of crucially important moments
in the story and I've been saying this
for years now but I really think that
some sort of major
Prison Break Ark might be coming very
soon after all
epic villains like all-4-one and stained
definitely need more screen time in the
story we haven't seen nearly enough of
them in my opinion back on the
battlefield
Aizawa endeavour Luke you and the other
heroes are attempting to restrain
shigaraki and while this is happening
gran torino takes deck 1 Baku go to a
relatively safe location some distance
away from the danger zone as endeavour
prepares to attack shigaraki the villain
is able to somehow jump high into the
air and use his electronic communicator
to issue the following command kill
everyone in sight now here's the strange
thing about she gotta keep being able to
do this in the previous chapter we saw
that he was knocked down to the ground
by Luke you and we also saw that his
quirks were being canceled out by
Eraserhead so how is he able to still
jump so high into the air wasn't his
ability to jump so high and move so fast
a direct result of one of the quirks
that he inherited from all-4-one it
turns out that no it wasn't there is
more to the new shigaraki than just a
bunch of overpowered quirks
just like the no move Segarra keys
actual physical body has been modified
by fujiko's procedure his natural body
now possesses superhuman strength all on
its own without the help of any specific
court so she Guara Keys natural body is
so strong that he is even able to
withstand endeavours attacks without the
help of a quirk although she got a key
definitely feels pain as a result of
endeavours attacks and he doesn't escape
injury nevertheless we know that as soon
as she got a key is able to use his
quirks once again those injuries won't
matter because he can just use super
regeneration to heal himself as the
heroes come to the terrifying
realization that she Guara keys power is
superhuman even when he can't use any
quirks
Fujiko explains to present Mike that
although she got Rocky's current
strength is not quite on par with all
might at his prime she Guara keys power
is now comparable to the physically
strongest of the normal like the usj
gnome
was able to go toe-to-toe against all
might at least for a while so just to
reiterate this whole time Eraserhead has
been looking at shigaraki non-stop and
effectively canceling out all of his
quirks but shigaraki is still able to
hold his own against the heroes
including the number-one pro hero by
using his physical strength alone that
is actually crazy I'm not gonna lie now
we need to talk about the absolute MVP
of this chapter and maybe even of the
entire arc my boy Manuel aka
the normal hero this absolute Chad comes
in clutch just at the right moment and
he uses his water quirk to moisturize
eraser heads eyeballs as he continues to
look at she got a key without blinking
this one move of epic bravery and skill
by manual ensures that Eraserhead
doesn't slip up and close his eyes which
would of course allow she got a key to
use all of his quirks again we could
definitely say that Manuel just saved
the lives of everyone in jakku city with
his incredible overpowered and
absolutely broken quirk but we can't
talk about Manuel forever even though he
definitely deserves it so let's talk
about some of the less important
characters gran torino leaves deco and
Paco go far away from the battlefield
and he tells them to stay there
baku go says that gran torino should
have dropped him off closer so that they
can actually contribute to the fight but
gran torino warns them that shigaraki is
insanely fast and so they can't be too
careful gran torino also says that the
heroes have a plan to defeat she gotta
keep and it is already working they've
managed to lure him into an area that
doesn't have civilians and they managed
to cancel out his quirks using Aizawa
gran torino announces that he is about
to go back to the battlefield but when
Deku complains about not wanting to just
sit there and hide gran torino gives him
a very stern warning shigaraki has
inherited all for one and all of its
incredible quirks and worse yet he is
determined to steal one for all if dec
who gets too close to shigaraki and
shigaraki is able to somehow steal one
for all then that would be the absolute
worst-case scenario she got a key is
already an overpowered monster and if he
somehow got his hands on one for all on
top of all these other quirks there may
literally not be any way to stop him
after that he might become unbeatable so
they must avoid this scenario at all
cost as numerous pro heroes approach the
battlefield in order to back up Aizawa
and the others gran torino is confident
that together they will be able to
defeat shigaraki despite his newly found
strength however in the very next moment
gran torino plan encounters a major
complication
all of a sudden a whole bunch of
high-end nomu emerge from the dust and
debris these are no mood that we haven't
seen before and there are at least nine
of them the heroes are shocked that
these normals somehow managed to survive
Shiga Rocky's wave of destruction and
that is when she got rocky reveals that
he has learned to control where his
decay is going to spread although it
seems that his control is not yet
perfect he managed to keep the decay
away from the tubes which were holding
these gnome and then he went on to use
the current from his radio waves quirk
to activate the nomal finally he gave
them the command to kill everyone in
sight earlier on in this chapter and now
these high ends are active and ready to
rampage as we are getting all of these
explanations for how the normal survived
we see a very powerful and disturbing
image we see shigaraki standing on top
of Endeavour and devar's flames are
extinguished and he looks beaten
shigaraki then raises his fist into the
air in the same way that all might is so
known for doing and in the same way that
all might famously did right after he
managed to defeat all four wandering the
Camino incident however because she got
a keys left arm has been terribly
damaged and charred and since he can't
heal it until he once again can use
super regeneration shigaraki raises his
other hand instead as he does this
shigaraki looks like a disturbing mirror
image of all might
the ante all might the true symbol of
evil definitely a powerful image and
potentially a sign of things to come now
let's get back to the know move it turns
out that these particular normal were
not quite ready to be deployed they had
not even reached the testing phase yet
so they are not intelligent basically
they cannot think for themselves and in
that sense they are similar to the older
nomu that we met much earlier on in the
story such as the usj gnome but
according to which code these new gnome
will have a level of strength that is
even higher than the other high ends so
even though they are not intelligent and
they can be outsmarted using the right
strategy they possess unprecedented raw
destructive power to make things worse
two of these nomal are currently heading
right for Aizawa and the heroes must
protect Aizawa at all cost because if
they don't
Sagarika will have full use of all of
his quirks and once again gran torino
rushes to help Aizawa and he tells deku
and Vaako go to hide and stay away from
the battlefield as shigaraki himself
also sets his sights on Eraserhead
our boy Izawa genuinely wonders if he is
about to die but he knows that he cannot
let himself be killed if he dies
shigaraki will be unstoppable
and besides Aizawa still has the
obligation to watch over his students
until they graduate and become pro
heroes just as shigaraki is about to
attack isola gran torino and law croc
prepared to sacrifice themselves by
putting their own bodies in between Iowa
and shigaraki however before she got Ike
he can kill anyone he is tackled by deku
and the power of one for all as a
surprise dies away looks on deck when
Paco go both vowed to save their teacher
they proclaimed that this time after
everything that I so has done for them
and after everything he has sacrificed
it is now their turn to save him and
that is how this epic action-packed
chapter ends Wow so much happened so
quickly
so many reveals we learned that
shigaraki has super
and strength even without quirks at
least 9 high-end normal managed to
survive and ever got wrecked by a quirk
less shigaraki and deco and baklava are
now going to go face to face against
shigaraki himself and we can't forget
that shigaraki now knows that dec who
possesses one for all so by coming here
dec who did exactly what she got lucky
wanted dec who might have had the best
of intentions but he has also just
completely invalidated the strategy of
the pro heroes and he has also just put
everyone in great danger if it turns out
that shigaraki is able to actually steal
one for all this is intense
and this is no joke deck one Bakugan are
now in the thick of it on the front
lines against shigaraki and this despite
the fact that they were specifically
told to stay away we always knew that
deco and the new shigaraki would have to
come face-to-face eventually but now the
big question is what happens next will
Dec will be able to unlock new quirks
and give shigaraki a run for his money
or will she got a key turned out to be
just too strong at least for now
will the Noma be strategically
neutralized because they don't have any
intelligence or will their raw power
lead to the deaths of many more Pro
heroes and finally will the other
villains like Dobby and Egan to machia
show up during this battle and throw
everything for an even bigger loop there
are just so many questions and I can't
wait for the next chapter
personally I definitely understand where
Dec was coming from and why he and Bach
ago decided to intervene they wanted to
help their teacher and having to just
hide and watch their mentors get killed
by shigaraki would have been an
incredibly difficult thing to do but at
the same time their decision just put
deco and Baku in mortal danger
so are they about to regret what they
just did please share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you enjoy the
book and all your content here on the
channel you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you have to be
new to an amount for or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification valve to turn on all
notifications you can also head me up on
Twitter and Instagram
at Anime uproar I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a very special thank you to a
friend a a disciple of Lord Twigg Oh
himself and I can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including in grata
alone Adam the world stealers acquired
respect pot a heffa Jonathan King deci d
brandon Avila's papa smurf
the school bus king riser emperor otaku
richie Martinez and Thomas Jones and of
course another big thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius Anatole
Kazansky on hell Cruz cricket XP Joe
Stanton very Gucci Alicia Akhter Jessica
Kay Lafond
Eno coming in water Bonnie parks Zoda
r12 rothwyn day Ora Emperor cynical
Kraken full gas 77 and deadly Saint if
you enjoy our videos then you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]